iein had always since childhood been
stronger and smarter than most of the
people around her which is great in
certain respects and very lonely in
other respects
I knew a great deal about her I'd known
her for 19 years and saw her constantly
during those years but I learned a lot
about Tiran researching the book when
you spent two-and-a-half years learning
about someone if you don't learn new
things about them you're not doing your
job properly
I spoke to over 200 people who had known
her from the time she was a child in
Russia up until the present time of the
book one of the things I learned that I
hadn't known was that her certainty
about herself had always existed
I talked to people who knew her when she
had just come from Russia and she was
talking then and when she barely spoke
English about writing a great novel and
she was totally convinced that she would
do it that she would know how to do it
people were not listened with the grain
of self to say the least
but she always knew what she wanted to
do always was determined to do it and
always was convinced that she could do
it
she was remarkable in that sense I I
never saw any any self-doubt in her any
doubt of her own powers of her own
ability so I can't say this was
something new what I learned is that she
had always been that way
not just during the years I knew her
I also learned some things I hadn't
known or at least known not fully known
that there were a lot of fears in her
life that which she didn't talk about
that she wasn't proud of the mind would
never have been proud of of anything
that frightened her but there were a lot
of fears for instance she would never
consider traveling to Europe because by
russian law she was still a russian
citizen and she was terrified that the
russians would kidnap her and take her
back to russia but they would know she
was an anti-communist she had a fear of
germs she would almost boil dishes when
she watched them that was certainly
understandable in Russia if you weren't
afraid of germs
you didn't understand the situation so I
discovered both strengths and weaknesses
in her and it was a fascinating process
she was a brilliant teacher and that's a
parent in a lot of her lectures and then
certainly in her conversations she had
an ability to know to sense some of what
her listeners needed to know in order to
grasp something and she she was a
wonderful wonderful teacher especially
the early days of knowing her when I
brought her all the questions of
adolescents that have been troubling me
is their free will things of that nature
what's moral how do we know what's good
and what's bad and it was just so
wonderful to have her start talking to
have those questions and those doubts
just fall away because of the sheer
logic of her presentation and I don't
mean I just sat and accepted at all we
would discuss argue but I felt like
she's answering questions that I've been
looking for answers for and nobody has
given me any sort of answer until now I
would bring her some of my textbooks and
I was studying philosophy and I would
read something in a philosopher that
didn't make sense to me but I couldn't
quite name what's wrong with it why why
is it not right if I was really stumped
I would bring the problem to her and the
problem would fall away in ten minutes
but that in mind that the joy of
watching that mind had worked was
something I've never experienced before
or since and I never expect to it was an
aesthetic pleasure to watch that mind at
work as well as a pleasure in the sense
of the ideas that she held and and
promulgated but it was a work of art
just to the functioning of that mind and
I never got over being thrilled by it
even sometimes when it was directed
against me I'd still be aware of what a
brilliant presentation of what's wrong
with me
well he represents in a way he
represents iron Rand because most of her
life was spent defending ability most of
John God's life was spent defending
ability which is why he organized the
strike in the first place so that in
that respect John gaunt design rant her
books were the equivalent of his strike
in that they were intended to say to the
world you had better start recognizing
human beings of ability or you're not
going to have a world left that was
God's message and that was irons message
from from we the living on it I hadn't
thought of it in these terms before you
asked the question but yes John Gogh was
iron random
my favorite section of the book that is
very strong impact on me
it's a scene Riordan is in his office
and he's thinking back on his life and
how he reached the stage success he now
enjoys and he's thinking of and he's
he's at a point where he's worn out
fighting and he slumped across his desk
feeling like he simply doesn't have the
power to he's not gonna be able to move
again he's just tired and sick and
disgusted with the impediments that have
been put in his way and he's thinking
about the stages by which he got to his
present success the nights the week's
the months of working of keeping at it
no matter what and then he thinks what
was the mode of power for my rise what
made it possible and then I earn rights
then with the greatest strength of his
life he slowly lifted himself off the
desk and sat up straight and began
working again the mode of power was his
determination and that rang all sorts of
bells for me it was very personally
meaningful and I will never forget that